في عالم تسود فيه مقاطع فيديو وميمات القطط
الشاطئ ، سترتفع شركة إعلامية واحدة
فوق الضوضاء ، هذه قصة كبيرة رائعة ،
حسنًا ، هذا رائع ، شكرًا
لك ، حسنًا ، هذا رائع الآن على
الرغم من ما تقصده ، هذه هي الطريقة التي
أتحدث بها دائمًا باسمي  هو فلفل أحمر ، أنا
فنان صوتي في المملكة المتحدة ، قام بصوت غريب عبر
مئات من مقطورات الأفلام ، رجال يرتدون
ملابس سوداء ينقذون الأرض من حثالة
مشروع نفوذ الكون Armageddon
Space Jam السيد.  Bean's Holiday حتى أن الكثيرين
ينسون نصفهم لكي يكونوا صادقين
معك ، لقد بدأت في عمل إعلانات تلفزيونية ، وكتب
صوتية متحركة ، وأقوم بالعديد من
ألعاب الفيديو ، بالإضافة إلى أن الكثير منها عبارة عن
مؤثرات صوتية للغول في
الخلفية عندما بدأت في التعامل مع
تجار الأفلام لأول مرة.  لقد كان ذلك ممتعًا عندما
يأتي رجل واحد قريبًا إلى السينما بالقرب منك
أحيانًا أقوم بتصوير أفلام رومانسية في
بلدة نائمة أحيانًا أفعل
ذلك.  أعماق
أحيانًا يتم التعرف عليّ ، لكن
بشكل عام لا ، لكن الوقت الذي أحصل فيه على
هاتف معترف به في القطار
مضمون ، مرحبًا والناس ينظرون من
وراء الصحف بالطريقة
التي أصبحت بها فنانًا صوتيًا كان نوعًا من
الغرابة التي اعتدت عليها  قيادة القطارات في
مترو أنفاق لندن في صباح أحد الأيام ،
كنت أقوم بإعلان جلسات إعلاناتي ، حيث
كان مديرًا تلفزيونيًا راكبًا
في قطاري الذي نزل من المحطة التالية ،
وركض إلى سيارة الأجرة الخاصة بي ، تفاصيل الصرف والدقة
لقد مررت ببعض التجارب الغريبة
كفنان شرطة كنت أقوم بعمل مقطع دعائي لفيلم
Jurassic Park ، فيلم العالم المفقود ستيفن
سبيلبرغ ، وتفضلوا باختياري
لأقوم بهذا الصوت في المملكة المتحدة وشيء
ما سيحدث شيئًا كبيرًا كما قلت ذلك  قال
صوت في سماعاتي إنه
صوت رائع ولم أتعرف عليه
مع ستيفن سبيلبرغ الذي كان يستمع
إليه من الولايات إلى لندن ، فهل
أقسم أنني قلت من هم أن
الجميع أصيب بالجنون في الاستوديو ، لا سيدي ، أنا
أقدر ما  أنا أفعل ما زلت
أدق ما أفعله أنا فخور جدًا
بما أفعله ،
أنا حقًا لا أنظر إليه على أنه عمل
أستمتع به ، إنه حقًا عمل رائع ،
يجب أن أكون هناك مع واحد  من
أروع الوظائف على هذا الكوكب
، صحيح ، لقد خرجت من هنا ،
هذا ملف